hace meses era sólo una perspectiva
lejana hoy finlandia rompió con décadas
de no alineamiento militar cuando
anunció oficialmente que quiere unirse a
la otan un giro provocado por la
invasión rusa y ucrania
hoy el presidente de la república y el
comité de política exterior del gobierno
han acordado conjuntamente que finlandia
solicitará el ingreso en la otan héroes
contra cotto anna aunque nato ya se
prevé consulta el parlamento de
hospitales y tan jóvenes han pasado
muchas cosas desde la última vez que nos
reunimos aquí el 24 de febrero si este
es un día histórico se abre una nueva
era
un camino que suecia también quiere
seguir el jefe de la otan james total
berg dijo que los dos países serán
recibidos con los brazos abiertos
finlandeses que son los socios más
cercanos de la otan su ingreso en la
otan aumentaría nuestra seguridad
compartida y demostraría que la puerta
de la otan está abierta
nate del sur y sobre el apoyo a la
adhesión a la otan ha aumentado
drásticamente en ambos países
todos los miembros de la alianza quieren
poner fin a esta guerra lo antes posible
pero estamos igualmente decididos a
mantener nuestra asistencia de seguridad
de ucrania señor continuar con nuestras
acciones controles de exportación y
presión diplomática sobre rusia mientras
rusia sigue con su guerra el ingreso de
finlandia y suecia en lo tan es
exactamente el tipo de movimiento que
moscú quería evitar cuando comenzó su
ofensiva
advirtió de las graves consecuencias
como la amenaza de desplegar armas
nucleares en kaliningrado este
territorio ruso está ubicado entre
polonia y lituania miembros de tan y de
la unión europea